-We're just over a month away
from the end
of the Trump administration,
and there are two things we know
for certain about this president
and his enablers
that we should never forget.
They tried to end democracy and
they tried to get people sick.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
There's a sense among some
Democrats, including apparently
President-elect
Joe Biden himself,
that Republicans
will just calm down
and become reasonable again
after Donald Trump
is off the political stage,
which is unlikely
for two reasons.
One, Trump will never
willingly leave the stage.
If he ever performed
at the Apollo,
he'd be the first contestant
to get into a fistfight
with the Sandman.
Trump's like someone who draws
out the "Happy Birthday" song
with lots of trills and "ayyyys"
when the rest of the office
wants to get back to work
and the Carvel cake is like,
"I'm melting over here."
It's basically a guarantee
that for the next four years,
he's going to be tweeting,
holding rallies,
and calling into Fox News
for those three-hour-long
therapy sessions
where the "Fox & Friends"
look like tourists
trapped on a subway car
with the guy feeding
the dead mouse to his pet Cobra.
I mean, Brian Kilmeade
already looks like
he's the only claymation
anchor at Fox News.
But when he doesn't blink
for an hour straight,
you'd think he was a
lesser-known Gumby character.
He's Dumby.
And the second reason --
that Republicans
weren't reasonable before Trump.
So there's no reasonable
to go back to.
A decade ago, they were famously
showing up to town halls
demanding to see Barack Obama's
birth certificate
and walking around D.C.
wearing long coats
and tricorn hats
like they waited too long to go
to Party City before Halloween.
"I'm a zombie, but from colonial
times.
Look, it's all they had left,
man."
And yet Biden seems intent on
trying to appeal to Republicans
in an attempt to return
to a bipartisan normalcy
that is impossible.
And even if it was possible,
it wasn't working
for most people.
Biden is reportedly considering
picking a Republican
to be Commerce Secretary.
And on Monday,
he told supporters
that Republicans
would come around
and return to normal
once Trump is gone.
-I predict to you,
and I may eat these words,
but I predict to you,
as Donald Trump's shadow
fades away, you're going to see
an awful lot change.
-And I may eat these words,
but, dude...
Don't get me wrong --
after the last four years,
it'll be nice to have
a president who's optimistic.
But sometimes optimism
can backfire.
Biden is like a football coach
in a sports movie
who says to a player,
"You may be the smallest kid
on this team,
but you got the biggest heart.
Now you go show him
what you can do!"
Then a week later, he's sitting
next to the hospital bed saying,
"Doc told me you broke
the leg in 50 places!
I didn't even know
that was possible!"
When it comes
to the Republican Party,
Donald Trump's shadow is
not just going to fade away,
at least not for a long time.
It probably won't even
leave the White House.
I wouldn't be surprised
if even after he leaves,
it's still there
wandering around alone,
where he used to
scream-answer questions
over the sound
of a helicopter engine.
If anything, they should
preserve his shadow.
His profile is so weird,
scientists should study it.
"Based on this shadow, what do
you think happened next?"
"He fell over forward?"
"No, he didn't.
It always looked like he was
about to, but he never did."
There are certainly no signs yet
that Republicans will suddenly
stop caring what Trump
thinks of them.
Even after he lost the election
and they were free of the need
to do his bidding,
they still tried to overthrow
democracy just to please him.
They know he's tapped into the
heart of the Republican base,
and they live in fear
of a primary challenge
or a nasty tweet from him.
-I think we know from what we've
seen with Republicans so far,
they're going to get on board
with this president.
There is no evidence to suggest
that there are Republicans
who want to cross
this president,
even though he has lost
this election.
They know he wants to remain
in power out of office,
and they're going to do
everything they can
to show this president loyalty.
They're going to do that
because they know if they don't,
this president
will tweet something.
Maybe he will back a primary
challenger against them.
So, no, I don't think there's
going to be any division.
The choice that Republicans
have had to make
is either be fully on board
with Donald Trump
or essentially leave the party.
-Yeah, it's like when you were
in high school at a party
in a friend's basement
late at night
and everyone started
doing whippets.
You can't just stand in a corner
and hope no one notices you.
you either man up and start
killing off brain cells
or go party with the chess club.
And again,
that joke is about chess
when I was in high school
and not now
when it's the hottest sport
in the goddamn world!
So turned on by chess,
I've started to refer to it
as pawnography.
Hit me with the crickets, Alex.
[ Crickets chirping ]
There it is.
Think about how servile
and cowardly you have to be
to live in fear of a nasty tweet
from the world's pettiest,
most irritating man.
I mean, he's tweeted
about me like 20 times,
including when he called me
"bland, weak, awkward,
and insecure," and said,
"His show is a cure for
insomnia," which is ridiculous.
You can't call it a cure yet
because we're still
in clinical trials.
Although early results
do suggest that our show
is 95% effective
at inducing sleep,
which is on par with Lunesta.
I'm coming for you, glow moth!
Also, you know why I think
Biden is wrong about this?
Because he was wrong
when he said basically
the exact same thing
eight years ago
before the 2012 election.
-I've said this to you before.
What we need
is a Republican Party.
We need leaders
that can control their party.
And I think you're going
to see the fever break.
-Not only did the fever
not break, it's spread.
Now we have to get
our temperatures checked
before we walk into
an Applebee's.
Biden thought the GOP's fever
would break,
and instead they elected a guy
who gave as many people fevers
as he could.
And even before that,
he just always looked like
he had a fever -- flush, sweaty.
He's basically every side effect
at the end of a drug commercial
rolled into one person.
The point is,
this is the Republican Party.
Trump is not an anomaly.
It was an unhinged authoritarian
movement before Trump,
and it's not going
to change now.
I mean, look at what they've
been saying even after
the courts and even the Trump
supporting attorney general
repeatedly made it clear
there was no evidence of fraud,
let alone widespread fraud
that would have changed
the outcome of the election.
-A large percentage
of the American public
does not believe the November
election results are legitimate.
-You think the election
was stolen, you tweeted out?
-Absolutely. I think there's
a great deal of fraud.
-As we await today's
Electoral College decision,
an intel source telling me
that President Trump did,
in fact, win the election.
He says that it is up
to the Supreme Court
to hear suits from other cases
across the country
to stop the clock.
-There are two
possibilities here.
One, an intel source with proof
of the election fraud chose
not to make that proof public,
but instead called
Maria Bartiromo
when it was too late
to change the outcome,
or two, one time,
Maria Bartiromo
yelled at the paper boy
for throwing her copy
of "The Bat[bleep] Times"
in her hedges,
and now he prank calls her
with hot tips.
"And you're saying Donald Trump
won the election?"
"Yeah, by, like, a lot."
Also, notice how Republicans
do this little rhetorical trick
where they claim that because
their voters
think the election was rigged,
that means we have to
restore faith in our elections.
-It is a serious problem
when you don't have confidence,
when such a high number
of Americans
don't have confidence in
the legitimacy of the election.
-Yesterday, I was talking with
some of the constituents
back at home,
group of about 30 people.
Every single one of them,
every one of them told me
that they felt
they had been disenfranchized,
that their votes didn't matter,
that the election
had been rigged.
These are normal,
reasonable people.
These are not crazy people.
-If they do think the election
is rigged,
it's only because you guys
keep telling them it's rigged.
You're the ones
causing this problem.
You can't then turn around
and say you want to solve it.
These guys are like bank robbers
stuffing cash
in a duffel bag saying,
"By the way,
you should really get some
security cameras in here."
The Republican Party
has spent the last month
actively trying to dismantle
our democracy.
There's no reason to believe
they'll suddenly change
and every reason to believe
this is who they really are.
I mean, the president himself
is apparently threatening
in private
not to leave the White House.
-Sources tell CNN that
the president has pulled a 180.
He used to privately
accept the reality
that he lost the election.
But now, no.
He's now starting
to believe his own lies,
that the election was stolen.
So much so that Trump
has told some advisers
that he may not leave
the White House
on Inauguration Day --
literally saying such a thing,
putting words to the sentiment.
And one adviser telling CNN,
"He's throwing an effing
temper tantrum.
He's going to leave.
He's just lashing out."
-He's like a kid who refuses
to leave the ball pit
at Chuck E. Cheese.
"Atticus!
Atticus, where are you?!
Atticus?!"
"Sir, adults aren't allowed
in the ball pit."
"I'm looking for my son.
Told him we have to leave,
but he refuses to accept
the results of the ball pit!
Atticus?!"
Obviously,
Trump won't be allowed
to stay in the White House,
but the fact that he's even
talking about it is insane.
I mean, what does he think
is going to happen?
Biden's going to move in,
and they're going to have to
share a bunk bed
like freshman year roommates?
[ As Trump ] Joe? Joe?
Joe?
Are you awake, Joe? Joe?
[ As Biden ]
What is it, Donny?
[ As Trump ] Do you think...
Rudy is a bad lawyer?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] And even after
the Electoral College
made it official on Monday,
Trump's allies on Fox News
are still acting like
there's some possibility
he could subvert
the will of the voters,
overturn the election,
and remain in office.
They can barely even bring
themselves to say the words
"President-elect Joe Biden."
-Steve Doocy's son Peter,
who has been
on the campaign trail,
and now he's with
what they're calling
the President-elect Biden.
-So does it bother you at all
that the son
of the former vice president,
who is,
according to some,
president-elect...
-Oh, Dumby. What do you mean,
according to some?
The Electoral College
literally just certified it.
The highest court in the country
has affirmed it twice.
Now it's not a matter
of opinion.
Joe Biden
is the president-elect.
These guys are talking about it
like we're all debating
the best Billy Joel song.
"According to some, it's 'Scenes
from an Italian Restaurant,'
but I think it's that weird
instrumental song
that sounds like the music
at a grocery store."
[ Soft piano music plays ]
All jokes aside, the best
Billy Joel song is "Vienna."
Oh, sure, you have your "Summer,
Highland Falls" dead-enders
and your "She's Got a Way"
heads,
but it's "Vienna," hands down,
debate over.
Again, there's no reason
to simply act like
the last four years didn't
happen
and the people that enabled
this monstrous administration
will suddenly become reasonable
participants in democracy again.
In fact, yesterday we found
from blockbuster new reporting
that a Trump appointee
at the Department of Health
and Human Services
actively advised the government
to let as many people
get coronavirus as possible.
While we all basically knew that
already
from, you know,
our eyes and ears,
seeing it written down
in an email was still shocking.
-New emails reported
by Politico today
show a Trump administration
official back in July
pushing the widely discredited
theory of herd immunity,
the idea of purposefully
infecting people,
wrote the then science adviser,
"Infants, kids, teens,
young people, young adults,
middle-aged with no conditions,
et cetera,
have zero to little risk,
so we use them to develop herd.
We want them infected
and recovered with antibodies."
We want them infected.
Experts say that would be
a disastrous course,
though it might explain
the refusal of the White House
to do more to stop the spread.
-"We want them infected."
That is some real super villain
[bleep] right there.
I mean, Bane might say that,
but even he wouldn't
put it down in an email.
[ As Bane ]
Batman, don't you see?
We want them infected!
CCing Alfred to make sure
you get eyes on this.
[ Normal voice ] Shoemaker,
my Bane's getting better.
No thanks to you.
[ Laughter ]
Every day I try to run
my Bane lines with Shoemaker.
"Oh, I'm too busy."
"With what?" I ask.
"Every part of this show
that's not you reading jokes
off cue cards," he says,
hurting my feelings.
How dare you!
On our Christmas show, no less!
[ Laughter ]
Just think about how monstrous
and sociopathic that is.
They wanted people to get sick.
I know in the Trump era, every
news story last five minutes
and our brains have
all been turned to mush
by the constant
crush of insanity.
But this story
should never be forgotten.
Anyone who enabled this should
be held accountable for it.
You can't just let
something like this go.
If you go through
your spouse's things
and find a bunch of love letters
to an ex saying,
"I want my husband to die,"
you don't just toss it
in the trash and say,
"Oh, well,
water under the bridge."
The Trump administration
may be coming to an end,
but there's no reason to think
this era in our politics
will end any time soon.
Trump has exposed a deep rot
in our political system
and within the Republican Party
that isn't going to just
magically disappear.
And we can't just forget
what happened here.
They tried to destroy
our democracy
and they stood by
as Americans died.
Say what you will about
the Republican establishment,
but at the very least,
it's clear they're either
dishonest people,
corrupt people, or...
-Crazy people.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.